this factory has been making turbines
for power plants the same way for
decades now vintage machines are
standard at the turbo atone company
the Ukrainian government is trying to
privatize state-owned corporations as
soon as possible but the workers are
skeptical they're afraid of job losses
I'm against privatization we should
remain a state-owned company and get our
orders from the state if we were
privately owned we'd have to get orders
by ourselves
turbo automa is based in Ukraine second
largest city Harkov during the Soviet
era Kharkov was a mighty industrial
center not much of that glory has
survived few factories withstood the
downfall of the Soviet Union
turbo automn is one of the few
exceptions the company's gigantic lathes
are used to manufacture parts for
Russian power plants but that part of
the business can't be sold on its own we
have a closed production cycle which
belongs together steel work mechanics
and testing the new government in Kiev
would like to sell off the remaining
state-owned corporations as a way of
making money but analysts are skeptical
few people in the government have any
experience in the complicated process of
privatization so they would be easy prey
for money hungry oligarchs revit ization
is not something which is dealing with
the quick wins who is the kind of
low-hanging fruits which they will take
it will immediately so that's why it's
in a way actually decision for the
medium-term and long-term perspective
turbo automn is modernizing its plant in
order to become more competitive and to
ultimately attract a European investor
the lathe is computer-controlled
improving its precision and speed but in
spite of these upgrades no one is
expecting privatisation to go quickly
executives are hoping for joint ventures
and partnerships we've entered into
negotiations with simens and the German
reconstruction bank about working
together to modernize turbines in power
generating plants turbo automn hopes to
get its foot in the door in Western
markets with this strategy and continue
to survive as a state-owned corporation